[Música]
y con nuestra segunda invitada del día
vamos a hablar de la última película de
disney encantó ya ha cautivado a
millones de seguidores y espectadores
alrededor del mundo una película que ha
sido aplaudida por la crítica por su
diversidad
étnica también de arquitectura su
realidad su apego a la cultura
colombiana y para ello entonces quiero
saludar a una invitada de lujo que
quiero muchísimo además que trabajó
conmigo aquí en esta casa francés y 4
estamos hablando de edna liliana
valència lily bienvenida qué bueno
tenerte nuevamente aquí en ese estudio
de france 24 para un muchísimas gracias
por la invitación estoy muy contenta
volver aquí al set de france 24 después
de cuatro años siendo parte de esta
familia pues es muy lindo volver a
charlar contigo así que gracias por la
invitación y ésta siempre será tu casa
alivio hablemos entonces de encanto
usted estuvo participando con el equipo
de creadores de esta película
específicamente en que se basó cuál fue
su trabajo en esta película porque
además es tan enriquecedora tan apegada
a la realidad colombiana paul pues te
cuento que tuve la gran fortuna y la
gran responsabilidad de formar parte del
equipo de cultural sost es casi que un
fondo cultural que conformó walt disney
para asegurarse de que cada detalle en
encanto sea fiel a la realidad
colombiana y que toda la gente se pueda
sentir identificada y eso en un país tan
diverso como lo es colombia pues
definitivamente fue un reto no los
directores de la película hicieron un
viaje de reconocimiento hace ya unos
cuatro años donde estuvieron por ejemplo
en el palenque de benkos de ojo en
cartagena cerca de cartagena en los
montes de maría pero también en
zipaquirá tuvieron por ejemplo gente con
ruana hacer el frío de la sabana norte
en cundinamarca y también la gente en
palenque con su idioma africano entonces
fueron convencidos de que la diversidad
cultural de colombia es una manera
también de reflejar esa diversidad de
américa latina y que debía quedar
constancia de eso en la película
entonces por un lado se fue mi trabajo
ayudarlos a representar de una manera
digna sin estereotipos una manera es
sobre todo muy fiel a la realidad a las
comunidades diversas sobre toda la
comunidad afro colombiana pero eso como
parte como te digo de un equipo de
cultural shows en el cual había también
architect
antropólogos historiadores historiadores
hombres y mujeres incluso gente experta
en botánica que diseñó cada planta cada
árbol cada pájaro cada especie el tucán
el chigüiro el jaguar el oso hormiguero
el oso perezoso todos están en la
película así que he estado en cuanto a
fauna flora y también como te digo la
música hizo parte de todo está de toda
esta apuesta de disney la gastronomía
las palabras palabras como vaca no como
parcero estar en la película muchos
gestos el tejo por ejemplo el único
deporte reconocido a nivel internacional
como creado en colómbia también está así
que bueno esa fue la apuesta y ese fue
el trabajo que hicimos lily cómo eran
esas sesiones de trabajo esos grupos de
trabajo tenían muchas preguntas la gente
dice y ustedes como los ayudaban como
enriquecían todo todo ese trabajo
cultural digamos que hicieron para
realizar encantó bueno primero que todo
contarte que el equipo de directores de
la película que hicieron parte de
también de toda esta apuesta fueron muy
amables fueron siempre muy cálidos
siempre una actitud como de admiración
por colombia eso me pareció muy lindo y
también pues era así pero entonces
cuántos habrá colombianos son no bueno
somos un 26% de la población es que la
cifra oficial es otras y por qué pasa
esto en unas conversaciones que
terminaban muchas veces casi que nada en
una masterclass de historia que hicimos
más del plan de historia fue con todo el
equipo de walt disney a cargo mío y
entonces eran muchos detallitos bonitos
qué opinas del cabello de este personaje
y yo miren esto es muy importante porque
walt disney siempre ha mostrado
princesitas blancas ozzie azules de
cabello liso entonces yo sí pienso que
el que colombia tenga la oportunidad
poner de presente un nuevo modelo de
belleza a nivel internacional ya muy
importante y yo en particular trabajé
mucho con los personajes afro de la
película félix antonio fueron los
principales con los que trabajé y nos
esforzamos mucho en detalles como el
cabello y entonces qué textura es pero
cada pero que tanto se va a mover la
ropa por ejemplo feliz que es un
personaje afro que es un hombre abro el
caribe te una guayabera que es una
prenda tan importante de la cultura
colombiana el caribe el sombrero
vueltiao no entonces bueno era siempre
muchas preguntas una actitud de mucho
aprendizaje y sobre todo mucho respeto
pues se llama el equipo de cultural
trust de estar seguros de que podían
confiar en su equipo de asesores que
junto con el equipo actoral y el equipo
musical logramos maravillosa y pienso
que no representa únicamente a colombia
sino a países como venezuela el área
para con que eso por ejemplo para toda
américa latina se va a poder ver
reflejada aquí y sobre todo en ese
factor de la diversidad que para mí es
tan fundamental ese sería el encanto de
la película lily para usted cuál sería
el encanto principal el encanto
principal de encanto es reflejar ese
país que nosotros somos pero no sabemos
que somos porque hemos estado muy
apegados a la versión negativa de lo que
es colombia hemos estado pegados de la
serie de narcos de la versión de la
guerra del conflicto pero normalmente
somos un país resiliente que ha sabido
ser un país de los más alegres del mundo
a pesar de un conflicto armado tan largo
que ha sabido mantener ese legado
musical y ese legado cultural a pesar de
tanta violencia y tanta guerra entonces
yo pienso que en canto muestra por un
lado si el referente del desplazamiento
forzado del conflicto armado de como
muchas mujeres quedan siendo mujeres
cabeza de hogar por culpa el
desplazamiento es por culpa de su esposa
han sido asesinados a causa de la
violencia pero también como la unidad
familiar es una característica de
colombia en la que nos saca adelante la
solidaridad de la comunidad también ha
sido fundamento y eso también se ve la
película así que el encanto es poder
vernos más como somos nosotros no somos
solo el país de la guerra y pienso que
cuando nos creamos la historia de que
somos mucho más que violencia entonces
ese referente autoconcepto va a cambiar
y pienso que para las nuevas
generaciones de niños y niñas
colombianos base fundamental verse desde
un país de la esperanza y no de un país
únicamente del conflicto lily y digamos
el equipo de disney cuando hace este
tipo de películas siempre hace una
investigación tan larga tan extensa de
años trabajando en el país donde se van
a enfocar y donde van a hacer esa
película además le quiero preguntar si
encantó pues le abre las puertas más al
universo de américa latina- a nuestros
países para representar otros países que
pues en este caso es colombia pero a lo
mejor uno centroamericano otro más al
sur usted que cree así definitivamente
walt disney es mucho más que una empresa
de dibujos animados es una empresa que
históricamente lo que ha hecho sentar
referentes lo que yo digo es por ejemplo
referente de la belleza estuvo marcado
por la princesita de waldeen durante
décadas si no es solamente que es una
película y ya sino que eso reproduce un
montón de imaginarios colectivos y por
eso la responsabilidad yo sé es tan
grande en términos de investigación
había una película latinoamericana en
este caso coco inspirada en méxico que
también tuvo un trabajo de investigación
muy fuerte que no conozco a profundidad
porque no hice parte de esa producción
pero definitivamente cuando son
películas que tienen que ver con un país
con una cultura con ello histórico en
particular el esfuerzo de disney en
cuanto investigación es muy importante
este trabajo con en capturó más de 5
años en investigación que digamos que sí
es maravilloso ver a voces como mauro
castillo por ejemplo es artista caleño
en la película parece silvia botero
haciendo a la abuela alma carolina
gaitán tanta gente alejandro riaño
digamos que ese es el toque actoral que
es maravilloso por el toque cultural es
todavía más digamos representativo en
cuanto a que la gente pueda
independientemente de que la historia
les guste o no sentirse identificados
con la imagen que se presenta el país
este trabajo investigación es muy
profundo definitivamente recorrieron
varias regiones del país barichara el
palenque vengo de ojo bogotá zipaquirá
bueno toda esa colombia que que ellos
decíamos es que esos son como varios
países en uno y estoy segura para
terminar estar dispuesto y decirte raúl
que si escogieron colombia también fue
porque colombia permite narrar
que la tiene en su diversidad la gente
afro que es más característica de brasil
de cuba república dominicana la gente
indígena que está mas en bolivia ecuador
méxico toda esa herencia también que
llegó españa no se le dice a blanco
mestiza en colombia está toda junta toda
reunida en un país del realismo mágico
que también eso todas las inspiraciones
de encanto la literatura gabriel garcía
márquez así que un resultado maravilloso
un país divino él y yo como venezolano y
ya va a tener aquí casi siete años y
medio un país enriquecedor que me ha
acogido como un hijo y bueno por
supuesto que representa encanto todas
las bondades de colombia porque es
verdad con toda la problemática que
tiene pero es un país maravilloso lily
muchísimas gracias entonces por estar
con nosotros hablar del trabajo que eso
dista y con esta nueva película encanta
invitación hoy viernes es que ya
terminaron de el programa y que se vayan
lo antes posible apenas habrá en la sala
de cine a ver encantó lily claro que sí
una invitación enorme de todas formas
independientemente que les parezca o no
perfecta la película no hay ninguna obra
de arte que sea perfecta ya tenés está
hecho para hacer perfecto sino para ser
transformador yo pienso que ese es
objetivos y se va a cumplir para que los
niños y niñas colombianos se vean con
otros ojos y queda fue vean como el país
del encanto y no solamente como el país
de la violencia